whether it's a wild celebration a somber
morning or the season finale of The
Bachelor hitting the bottle is not
uncommon what's a bit more unusual
though is getting your drink on at your
place of work at most jobs this is a big
no-no but in Hollywood things are a
little different
this is equal parts scotch absinthe rum
gin vermouth triple sec and two packs of
Splenda whether it inspired great
performances or cause some disastrous
behind-the-scenes drama here are some
stories of actors who were drunk during
filming Denise Richards and Neve
Campbell it doesn't matter who you are
if you find yourself kissing a girl for
the first time in your life naked in a
pool surrounded by a film crew a
cocktail or five might be in order that
was definitely the case for actresses
Neve Campbell and Denise Richards who
needed some liquid courage before
filming their famously steamy scene from
wild things this was going to be the
first time either of the actresses had
kissed a girl before so they decided to
take the edge off by pounding back an
entire pitcher of margaritas before the
cameras started rolling looking back on
the kiss now Campbell said it was
actually pretty fun and that they were
definitely thankful for the pre-filming
drink Daniel Radcliffe by the time
Daniel Radcliffe turned 18 and was
filming his sixth Harry Potter movie he
found himself quite lost in the drink
what started out as a fun lifestyle of
partying quickly degenerated into a
serious problem that found Radcliffe
blacking out multiple times per week the
actor did his best to keep some distance
between his work and his drinking and he
maintains that he never actually drank
on the Harry Potter set Radcliffe has
admitted however that he often would
show up in the morning still drunk from
the night before and would start
shooting while clearly still under the
influence the actor claims he can tell
which scenes he was inebriated for but
he's understandably refused to share
that information with the public the
only solution to this predicament set
aside a weekend and have yourself an
eagle-eyed Harry Potter movie marathon
and maybe a few drinks to Robert Shaw
it's no secret that actor Robert Shaw
liked to drink
and as it turns out this affinity for
the bottle affected the actors famous
performance in 1975 s jaws before
filming a particularly tricky monologue
Shaw asked director Steven Spielberg if
he could have a bit to drink to help him
loosen up
unfortunately that bit to drink resulted
in Shaw showing up to the shoot
completely wasted the actor wasn't able
to perform the scene and ruined the
entire shoot for the day the next day
Shaw showed up to set with his tail
between his legs and was very apologetic
for the way he acted
Spielberg forgave him Shaw knocked the
scene out of the park you know the thing
about a shaggy
and the rest is history
Martin Sheen of all the famous film
shoots in the history of Hollywood
perhaps none are quite as legendary as
the set of Apocalypse Now leading man
Martin Sheen was a late addition to the
film and when he arrived he found a set
in chaos needless to say he wasted no
time diving right into the thick of it
apparently director Francis Ford Coppola
kept Sheen locked up and completely
hammered for days on end in an effort to
get the emotionally driven performance
he was looking for Coppola even toyed
with Sheen's psyche telling the actor
that the rest of the production team was
evil and out to get him the performance
ended up being pretty amazing but it
sounds like Martin Sheen went through a
drunken hell to get there Margot Robbie
Australian foreign actress Margot Robbie
is one of the most sought-after
actresses working today still her big
break might never have happened if it
weren't for a helpful crew member who
happened to have some booze on hand on
the set of the wolf of Wall Street
Robbie had to bare all and the actress
was very nervous for the nude moment she
knew eventually she'd watched that scene
with her dear Mum Ashley tried to cover
her eyes when the nude bits happen but
she pushed my hand away luckily a member
of the production team offered Robbie
some tequila to help her calm her nerves
she quickly threw back three shots and
was ready to roll the scene turned out
great and Robbie credits the booze for
helping her nail the r-rated moment Brad
Pitt and Edward Norton despite how tight
the script seemed
were several improvised moments during
the filming of Fight Club on top of that
improvised hit the scene in which Brad
Pitt and Edie Norton drunkenly smack
golf balls from their house was also
unplanned and surprisingly method the
actors who had bonded on set had
actually gotten drunk together and
started smacking golf balls at the
film's catering trucks when Fincher saw
them he thought it fit their rebellious
characters and decided to roll the
cameras Pitt remembers the drunken
sequence fondly and this honest moment
of bonding not only helped the actors
get closer but actually gave birth to
one of the more popular scenes from the
film Peter O'Toole and Omar Sharif the
late Peter O'Toole was almost as famous
for his drinking as he was for his
acting by the time the actors starring
role in Lawrence of Arabia came about he
was already well versed in the art of
onset drinking and he decided it was
time to spread the wealth during the
famous a cover scene O'Toole's co-star
Omar Sharif was terrified of falling off
his camel and he considered tying his
legs to the animal but O'Toole had a
different plan in mind he suggested that
they ought to just get drunk and let the
rest work itself out Sharif obliged and
the two proceeded to get sloshed on
brandy and milk O'Toole and Sharif ended
up delivering some of the most famous
performances in film history
thank you alcohol thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to
you